donne qu'est ce que vous appelez un
portable voilà vous avez sûrement région
monsieur marc javelle est la question
posée est une question très importante
qu'il ne faut pas négliger et ni passer
sous silence
il y a en effet ce que monsieur rappelle
les prototypes
il y également ce qu'il appelle le
prêt-à-porter des couturiers
mais il faut également être conscient je
pense qu'on sera tous ici de bonne foi
que même ces prix là je parle des prix
du prêt-à-porter
ces prix là sont souvent trop cher c'est
vrai mais faut voir les choses avec
honnêteté et clarté c'est cher parce que
et c'est très bien parce que l'évolution
sociale a fait que tout est cher que la
main d'oeuvre est très cher que les
charges sociales sont très chers et je
suis le premier à me réjouir
il y avait trois semaines de vacances il
y en a quatre et salaires ont augmenté
dans des proportions considérables
je sais très bien qu'on peut trouver des
choses très bon marché à gauche ou à
droite
seulement ne perdez jamais de vue que
ces choses-là sont faites sur
l'exploitation totale et profonde des
travailleurs il y à telle usine à brest
où l'on paye des salaires dérisoires et
où l'on fait manger les gens ou à coup
de sifflet de coup de sifflet pour
manger un sandwich à coup de sifflet
pour sortir à ce moment là on peut
sortir probablement et vendre des
produits très bon marché en ce qui nous
concerne la maison que je représente
nous refuserons à de telles pratiques et
je ne crois pas qu'on puisse aujourd'hui
donner des produits de qualité portant
notre nom et je pense avoir votre appui
là-dessus eux obtenu dans de telles
conditions
et ça m'apparaît important est vrai
monsieur vergès et je crois que c'est un
faux problème pardon monsieur fayard 16e
scolastique qui consiste à savoir si
love sort de la poule où la poule de
l'oeuf est complètement dépassée qui a
fait la mini jupe qui a fait le pantalon
qui a fait le long qui a fait le court
le rouge ou bleu ne veut plus rien dire
je crois jeu comme je l'aï dit tout à
l'heure que cela vient de très profond
courant mais où la haute couture a son
rôle et son rôle le plus important c'est
que on dira peut-être et mon propos
n'est pas de vous attaquer on dira
peut-être que la mini
défaite en angleterre par je ne sais qui
il n'empêche qu'il a fallu attendre
courrèges et un couturier un grand
couturier pour cette mini jupe base et
passe réellement dans le public
voilà le rôle de la haute couture le
pantalon et été par tout le monde
il n'empêche qu'il a fallu attendre
saint laurent avec une collection femme
sur les pantalons pour que ce pantalon
passe également la république voilà
l'importance des nationaux
[Musique]